the jurgen experience meat is the most
nutrient-dense perfect food for humans
it just is it's such an exhausting
conversation when you say that to people
though like you said i think you know
you're eating all that meat like what
about your cholesterol what about you
gonna have a heart attack yeah and it's
working its way into policy which is
really disturbing to me like as a mother
like new york city public schools vegan
on fridays now in addition to meatless
mondays so now you've got
a school system where seventy percent of
the kids are economically disadvantaged
and might go home on the weekends like
they need school lunch right and now
you're bet you're you're flanking the
weekends with nutrient poor both friday
and monday and it's this ideologically
driven thing that's based on this idea
that if you eat less meat it's better
for the environment like this thing that
they say and they also say for health
purposes like right oh they'll cite the
china study like it's one study
and like no matter how much you say like
hey you need to read the rebuttals of
the china study yes they're pretty
brutal and it's it shows that it's a lot
of biased evidence and that they really
didn't do a good job of being objective
about that so there's one thing that's
that's coming up that's happening right
now that's really interesting so there's
this thing called the global burden of
disease
and this is published by the landsat
and it's what most global food policy is
set on
and between their report in 2017 and
meat was 36 times more likely to kill
you
and
there were some researchers some friends
of mine that pushed back they wrote a
letter to the landsat which was blocked
the landsat uh it sounds like it's
finally going to be publishing it like
over the next couple days
finally publishing this thing that says
that meat is 36 more times oh no that's
out the 2019 global burden of disease is
out and i actually had a um
a graphic on that just to show what are
you saying is going to be published so
some friends of mine
right because these guys didn't provide
any evidence at all
uh as to why meat so there's this
theoretical minimum risk exposure level
that
you know is supposed to be the safe
level of meat you can eat and it went um
down to zero
according to these researchers
which is going to be
a global food policy
you can now eat zero red meat safely
with no so that they said they did their
own systematic review but they were they
didn't show any of the evidence any of
the papers they reviewed and there
aren't there's no research that's strong
that's showing
meat is there's only one randomized
control trial if they're not showing
evidence any evidence they're not
showing any papers
how is this how is this science
right and so
finally the landsat is going to publish
this paper where
my
colleagues are questioning
the results and where is the science
and the landsat i mean the global burden
of disease is the landsat
this is a really
very big deal
so i don't understand like what is there
i always thought that with scientific
papers you had to cite sources and you
had
so
up until about two years ago that was
pretty consistent and then i think we've
seen a loosening of standards here's the
difference between 2017 and 2019. so you
can see
the top part is what we're doing in
excess and you can see that diets high
in red meat used to be
a very small percentage of like the
cause of death globally
which is even a silly thing but it was
it used to be sodium was much higher and
now meat has gone up do you see this 36
times more likely to be the cause of
death
how's that in two years so this is the
study this is and
this analysis when when they're doing
this how are they coming to this
conclusion
right nobody knows nobody tell you
they're just saying it they're just
saying it so what is their motivation
we don't really know
um
i mean a little tin foil hatty i i think
that there's a powerful desire to
consolidate food production globally and
this is an amazing way to do it it's uh
the as it is there's i think that six or
seven companies produce like 90 percent
of the food that's consumed globally but
what we've seen over time is just more
consolidation more consolidation and
there's this kind of weird interface
between tech and venture capital and
food there have been some interesting
pieces where folks are looking at food
like they want it to be operated like ip
like software they want you to be able
to own the interesting you say that
because bill gates is now the
largest owner of farmland in the united
states yeah we looked at that up once
there was some sort of dispute about
that but then we looked at it said he
was
is one of the major sponsors of the
study that i was just talking about so
it's so and but the thing is
that he keeps saying that we've gotta
eat less meat and you know we've got to
cut our consumption of meat out to be
healthy and then we're going to get used
to these meat alternatives when a guy
like that says that i'm like are you
making money because of this like why
are you saying that and by the way you
look like because if you're eating
those those plant-based burgers or
whatever the you're doing like
you're obese like a guy like that
telling people about he's got these
breasts and this this gut and i'm like
this is crazy you're one of the richest
guys on earth you have access to the
best nutrients the best you could have
an amazing trainer you you could be in
phenomenal shape and you're giving out
public health advice
you're giving out health advice and
you're sick it's like
literally like a non-athlete trying to
coach professionals like what the
are you talking about how are you giving
any health advice when you look like
that your health is piss poor i'm not a
doctor but when you've got man boobs and
a gut and you're walking around you have
these like toothpick arms i'm like hey
buddy
you're not healthy
there's a lot of profit to be made in in
processing something into
a beyond burger there's a lot of profit
to me but those aren't even selling
anymore have you noticed that yeah
we're kind of lucky in a way like the
the consumers kind of got in and poked
around that and there was uh forbes did
an interesting piece where they there
was so much interest from the vegan
community around impossible burger and
impossible foods and the swarps piece
was interesting it made the case that
these people are usually very
progressive and very anti-corporation
we're like the biggest fans or or you
know promoters of this corporatization
of our food system which is kind of
where all the stuff is going what we're
duped
they really are but you know it's on the
one side there's a story that meat will
cause cancer and diabetes and all this
stuff and it's going to destroy the
planet because of carbon emissions and
it's using all the water and the land
and it's a it's a slick story it's a
it's an elevator pitch it's elegant it's
like buttoned up airtight and then when
we start trying to unpack that
i
you have to dig into ecology and
non-equilibrium thermodynamics and it's
not an elevator pitch and
it's a lot of work to to unpack what
those claims are and then you know even
what is the motivation to do this then
we start getting into conspiracy theory
land it's like well there are people
that want to control the food system and
they want to you know turn food into
intellectual property that they own
but
that really seems to be what's going on
with this and and i think they're
they're not they've realized consumers
aren't going to just buy it in the
grocery store and by the way it's twice
as expensive like beyond burger is twice
as expensive as organic grass-fed beef
per pound wow but they sell it in
half-pound packages right next to the
pound packages and so they trick you
but so why not just make it policy and
indoctrinate these kids from
kindergarten to age 12 with these
messages like the meatless monday
messages are all wrong
like where's the message uh meat is bad
for your health and the environment and
and they use these beautiful simplistic
infographics
showing you know livestock takes up
three quarters of the land
but but
okay but it's not talking about the
types of land you know or that your
burger used 10 bathtubs full of water
but then we're not talking about okay
the the most of the water footprint for
a cow
is actually in the grass it's called
green water it's like water that's
already
in the environment
in rain
whether the cow is there or not it's
going to happen do we have that
infographic yeah i have the water you
want to talk about how much water
a burger uses up you better not be
eating almonds
exactly yeah you better not be you
better shut your mouth if you're eating
almonds right yeah those things are
ridiculous so here's the water one and
i've broken it down land use feed use
but this is just the water one and so
what most people don't get is that
there's you know green waters natural
rain
and then the blue water is like what
when you look down on a map and see
rivers and lakes so what we're looking
at folks that are just listening is when
you look at typical beef versus
grass-finished beef it looks like
there's probably like
how many dots are on a little different
so we're at the bottom i have the
percentages so it's 94 green water for
typical beef and 97
green water for average and this is
average like in vermont it might be
different than nevada but so they have
it broken down to these droplets and
these droplets 100 droplets on each side
and two droplets
from the grass finished beef are lake
streams and underground water three
droplets from the typical beef
so and that's what everybody's concerned
about what people are really concerned
about that's concerned about the
draining of the lakes and streams and so
it's not drinking water right
and the rest of it the entire graph is
natural rain which is rain that exists
with moisture that exists in vegetable
matter yeah and i mean it's going to
fall on this land which is land that has
been grasslands for eons and we can't
use it for anything else when people say
we
we use all this land for cattle
that's
you know bison are a good example i'm
good friends with the folks that own
roam free bison ranch in montana they
they do both cattle and bison because
the cattle don't go up these super steep
mountains and so the you know they're
these grassland
mountains
that the bison graze and if they don't
graze it then the whole ecosystem just
collapses the the
the ecosystem has been this plant animal
interaction for millions of years and
this plant animal interaction is based
on the animals manure
fertilizes the plants the animals eat
the plants dung beetles insects birds
you know all the stuff so it's not
stealing land from anything this is what
grasslands do it's not stealing water
from anything this is the rain sleet and
snow that falls on the grasslands and
these animals should be there because
it's part of a healthy ecosystem like
the audubon society in the last 10 years
has been getting really
involved in regenerative ag because one
of the first things that they see when
people start doing pasture-based meat is
that the bird species come back and come
back in in remarkable profusion because
it starts fixing if you fix all of the
ecosystem issues then these literal
canary and the coal mines end up getting
addressed and we see more bird species
come back